welcome to this video playing horse a
horse a Sunday hosts a Sunday I don't
know from Spain come on play a move I'll
take every legal move yeah but this one
I don't you get be three rather off here
it must be some sort of fun yeah it's
it's it seems to be an in fashion for
some reason they have been some games of
course recently bye-bye stronger players
like Jabbar ba Richard report but still
ok is playing a sort of reversed I know
reverse Sicilian hedgehog whatever mmm
what is this age 6 h foyer really now if
we probe this is doing that if I go age
6 ok I better get to get some play in
the center going ok so if I go if I do d
4 here he can take e 4 but this is
certainly some compensation d 494 be
sure that five maybe
yeah tricky yeah I spent so much time
again but okay it's always so if they
play some solve this kind of extreme
opening you at least try to really am
really reviewed it or at least try to
find the most principled way to play you
cannot speak off a refutation yeah but
just playing yeah I tried to play good
moves and not just dash out whatever
comes to mind first you know okay do I
have compensation here questionable very
complicated I didn't expect that one but
Yampa let's go d3m try to try to help as
development I probably can play night H
form I mean okay move the night again
but mmm getting rid of this is is a good
idea
between the queen d 1 i'm planning
Bishop c5 p.m. where i can take with
that pawn maybe this is maybe an idea
get their farm yeah
yambar should be five was my idea
technically covering this for the moment
maybe I should have thought about 94
here unnai g4 would have been
interesting yeah of course those kind of
no return moves get played instantly and
the reason why I'm a bit skeptical about
it is Nigel form this piece sec after
that he has really problems to to get
his pieces coordinated but maybe he can
click will be to and castling long yeah
this might be might be the the defense
maybe
fatigues if not directing are thinking
of Queen g5 as well but this is probably
not not sufficient queen d 3982 still
not it's not not completely easier is
having second thoughts here interesting
but here i can i can maybe take a for
and black queen d 4 but that's very
interesting let's let's try that I now I
get it for I will get to f2 we m this is
really totally mixing our whites
coordination I can take f4 let's add
some know this is tricky not sure if
it's objectively working but this is
very very dangerous
there may be 94 wasn't the best very are
very tough to play this tough to
calculate how to say what you will play
now okay here yeah the check is not
leading to too much Kim D 1 93 is not
working you can just take that okay i'm
not sure most playing this is not bad I
guess as known i def to s 0 is a big
threat and he's really completely
without any coordination maybe can play
king see one king be two or something
okay yeah I can yeah this is not not
leading to that much I would love to get
the routine to play but King b2 is not
possible maybe just rupee you one we can
take him he can take here okay let's
start with night f2 I must start with
night f2 and now maybe we'll create to
have rookie one let's say queen bee 294
and rookie one mate this is the stuff he
can he can he cannot move any piece here
it's all it's all hampered
it's funny with the rook down
I really don't see more I think white is
toast here
I'm threatening just to move you out
this is maybe this one I'm okay I'm
taking what take take h2 we have is the
quite the that's that's really funny now
I'm threatening to take me to end the
roof yeah okay I maybe this wasn't the
best even right time morning check
Brooke cakes and still Queenie 5 and
rooty 225 now or taking on d to check
check
hmm stare wind really I don't see a win
95 he's got big problems with the time
of course but I still like to have a
real win here check check check with the
line shack warheads it will check on sea
foam oh so what's just what is this at
the end I've got three points for the
exchange not clear at all pool yeah okay
so maybe I should have should have taken
this night immediately this this was the
right I checked I'm doing something
wrong here yeah of course I can take you
1 i'm in such an idiot i can just take
you 1 of course prix takes 90 shiny okay
so this was the point okay and here it's
not not such an easy win yeah i can just
take a look yeah i was God that the
thing was I had overlooked I was taking
here check I had a total of a look that
Quincy Falls with the check of course
check is this was what's the problem I
mean okay yeah I can also just play any
movement win on time but I don't want to
do that and I add the end of one on some
chocolate check yeah but let's let's
briefly check if this was really working
in some way at least okay i guess the
spawn sacrifices rather rather yeah
quite quite a gamble and not not really
working here it was interesting to to
play Knight g4 but i was i was too quick
with Bishop b5 now g4 is very
interesting here because what what is
this move something like that is
not great or queen age was even stronger
this would have been interesting but ok
this was what I had to plan beforehand
and no f4 was playa and now this this is
just just the big gamble here I think
you should take it they're not so sure
what I'm actually doing after that I was
thinking maybe this one and this is at
least they're very irritating we're
computer wants to play here here here
and defend this yeah this should be good
for item it's it's a piece and it's a
whole piece I don't have any points for
that why does uncoordinated so it's it's
not so easy for a human to play but
objectively it is not working ok he went
90 for andrew care for is winning in DTM
it just felt like the right move to me
and it's it's really winning my
mathematically winning check with ok
Queen f4 was even stronger interesting
yeah maybe because white really doesn't
have a move here it's again the problem
he cannot really do something this does
rook d 8 which is super strong wow yeah
d to assign collapsing yeah this is
stronger White has no move here the
computer wants to play king d 1 check
and return return all material here with
the total win for black so this is this
is even more convincing but this what
about this ok is also minus minus 3 yeah
then it was almost a quite interesting
game at least I mean I only a should
have checked should have taken here
should have taken a look here to win but
okay the time in this case help me okay
thanks for watching